france 2022 l'heure du choix c'est tous
les lundis désormais vous le savez à
20h10 heure de paris puis à partir du 14
mars tous les jours avec vous achetez
verdien bonsoir raphaël bonsoir à tous
l'europe s'est invitée dans la campagne
à la présidentielle ces derniers jours
temps forts le discours des manuels mac
comptes devant le parlement européen où
il a exposé ses priorités pour l'europe
l'opposition s'est saisi l'occasion pour
critiquer l'action du chef de l'état et
l'instrumentalisation du presque
candidat de cette tribune des échanges
qui ont donné qu'ils ont donné au
parlement européen des herbes
d'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs où en
est emmanuel macron dans son cheminement
vers l'officialisation de sa candidature
le récap politique est signée florent
rodo et jouer le procope
c'est l'histoire d'une annonce qui se
fait attendre
bonjour
campagne à la campagne pour emmanuel
macron toujours pas candidat ma décision
l'union des droites pour eric zemmour
c'est yes we can
entouré de ses nouveaux amis du r n ai
de l air ambiant ce relevé est main
tendue aux électeurs du front national
qui n'en pouvait plus de perdre avoue
électeurs et républicains qui n'en
pouvait plus de voir vos dirigeants
traille à vos idées unissons nos forces
se serrer les coudes à défaut de se
serrer la main vendredi chez le droitier
laurent wauquiez samedi chez les
centristes
superbe mission grand écart pour valérie
pécresse mes amis avec vous aujourd'hui
je sens s'élargir la droite la france
que nous aimons nous allons la redresser
ensemble avec tous ces talents
[Applaudissements]
du talent pour ne rien faire
emmanuel macron en a selon yannick jadot
de quoi lui décerner un nouveau titre
resterait dans l'histoire monsieur le
président de la république le président
de l'inaction climatique
lui restera comme le président qui ne
s'est pas représenté talaq françois
hollande songerait-il à revenir je suis
pas candidat a pu remarquer mais comme
ça va pas bien c'est vrai que
[Musique]
choisir parce qu'une candidature de plus
je serai utile je ne sais pas chef de
l'état lui ne le sera pas exceet arnaud
montebourg qui dans cette campagne
marché bien trop seul je crois inutile
et désespérant d'ajouter du désordre la
confusion d'un trop grand nombre de
candidatures vive la france et à bientôt
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
vivement la prochaine
[Musique]
et on veut maintenant revenir sur la
lutte fratricide au sein de l'extrême
droite entre eric zemmour et marine le
pen une réalité encore exacerbées ces
derniers jours alors que candidat du
parti reconquête a débauché plusieurs ex
soutien de la candidate du rn dernier en
date l'euro débute et gilbert collard on
en parle avec rosine faire chef du
service politique de france 24 bonsoir
roselyne les débauchages se succèdent ce
qu'ils pourraient continuer alors ça
c'est la surprise du chef mais entre
marine le pen vous avez remarqué ce
n'est pas une histoire des mots mais
plutôt celle qu'on raconte aux enfants
l'histoire du grand méchant loup alors
vous savez celui qui entre dans la
bergerie et qui vient dévorer les
gentils than you mais on l'a bien
compris le rassemblement national n'est
pas une bergerie et
les ceux qui sont partis avec le loup ne
sont pas forcément très gentil en tout
cas ils sont partis sont partis avec
eric zemmour il s'agit de jérôme rivière
un eurodéputé damien rieu qui connaît
damien rieu comme dirait ségolène royal
un proche en tout cas de marion maréchal
et vous l'avez dit gilbert collard
l'avocat
tonitruant alors aujourd'hui histoire de
marine le pen c'est un peu l'histoire de
l'arroseur arrosé pourquoi parce que
elle avait un rêve marine le pen c'est
d'être celle qui allait prendre la
droite en tout cas qu'ils allaient faire
venir qui allait piquer aux républicains
ou à l'ump des gens de la droite et
faire sa propre bergerie avec les déçus
de l'ump ou des républicains alors elle
a réussi à attraper on l'a vu thierry
mariani mais il n'a pas fait de grandes
étincelles notamment pour les régionales
quelques mois il ya quelques mois encore
marine le pen était seul sans son
créneau c'est à dire que l'extrême
droite personnes venaient la déranger
dans sa petite boutique même si on avait
le sentiment que gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur avait comme une
prééminence en pensant en la traitant de
mol qu'elle était qu'elle était un peu
molle au niveau de l'immigration
avec zemmour justement son procès en
mollesse et bien pouvait commencer il a
tenté de la ringardise et de dire que ce
qu'elle disait était pas assez pas assez
fort que son parti était mort c'est vrai
que le rassemblement national n'a jamais
été aussi concurrencer sur sa droite on
se souvient de jean marie le pen avec
bruno mégret qui avait tenté
l'expression de le pen de faire un
putsch mais c'était rester c'était resté
sans sens aventure aucune et le menhir
jean marie le pen son surnom était resté
jean marie le pen gilbert collard jérôme
rivière ses débauches est un coup dur
pour le rn roselyne pas disons que c'est
un débauchage classique 1
la vue tout le monde tous les partis
politiques ont fait ça c'était d'aller
d'aller chercher ce qu'on appelle des
prises de guerre mais ça arrive quand
même à un très mauvais moment ça arrive
à un moment où marine le pen en tout cas
est très concurrencé je les dis par par
zemmour et
eric zemmour lui il a il traverse un
creux nettement il est en baisse dans
les sondages il est devancé par marine
le pen et valérie pécresse donc il
essaie comme dans la série d'une série
netflix de créer des rebondissements de
l'action de la trahison alors il donne
toujours il veut donner ce sentiment ce
que le pen est finie qu'elle est
ringarde que lui il est moderne il vise
son électorat bien évidemment mais
quand on regarde de près et bien on se
demande
ils se battent pour quoi en vérité ils
se battent pour la reconstruction la
reconstruction de l'extrême droite et
donc avec son parti est bien et moore
qui l'a appelée reconquête espère bien
tuer le rassemblement national même si
elle est en tête août elle arrive au
deuxième tour et qu'elle ne gagne pas il
espère lui en tout cas montrer que c'est
lui qui fera qui fera qui gérera la
boutique de l'extrême droite par la
suite
merci beaucoup aux aînés je le rappelle
on vous retrouve dès demain dans une
version longue de votre émission mardi
politique co présentée avec frédéric
rivière de rfi et vous recevez de main à
nathalie arthaud candidate lutte
ouvrière à la présidentielle
on l'a évoqué a tout à l'heure h he est
le thème de l'europe s'est imposé dans
cette campagne présidentielle notamment
à l'occasion de la semaine dernière on
l'a vu à strasbourg les candidats se
sont positionnés sur la question des
frontières de l'union européenne et qui
lie frontières dit politique migratoire
absolument de nombreux candidats ou
quasi candidat comme emmanuel macron
souhaite une réforme de l'espace
schengen et sans surprise à droite et a
fortiori à l'extrême droite on va
beaucoup plus loin eric zemmour dit même
assumer une position anti immigrés en
thèmes qu'il a développés lors de sa
visite à calais près de l'ancienne
jungle de migrants une visite qui a
donné lieu vous le voyez à une
manifestation de militants anti
fascistes alors comment ces débats sur
l'immigration sont ils perçus aux
frontières de l'union
direction tout de suite le camp de
migrants de l'île grecque de samos situé
à deux kilomètres à peine de la turquie
c'est l'une des portes d'entrée des
migrants dedans lieu le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin mais aussi
la candidate heller valérie pécresse s'y
sont récemment rendues un reportage
signé à de notre envoyé spécial alexia
kefalas ce
samos le 15 janvier dernier valérie
pécresse profite de sa visite au nouveau
centre de demandeurs d'asile de l'île de
la méditerranée pour donner à sa
campagne une dimension plus
internationale
je pense que cet endroit est tout à fait
exemplaire
l'exemplarité d'un pays la grèce qui a
décidé de contrôler réellement ses
frontières l'icône faut vite frontières
un exemple d' équilibre entre fermeté et
humanité sur la candidate la fermeté ce
sont des barbelés qui s'étale sur 12
mille mètres carrés des caméras de
surveillance tous les 10 mètres et des
scanners à rayon x une masse de faire
entièrement financé par l'union
européenne
l'humanité selon valérie pécresse serait
les aires de jeux et les chambres toutes
équipées en tout cas une semaine après
cette visite les commentaires de la
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
font toujours débat d'un côté les
autorités savoure nous sommes ravis
d'être érigée en modèle c'est bien pour
la grèce mais il faut que ce soit aussi
porté en europe parce que le dossier
migratoire va continuer de peser
mais les exilés n'apprécie pas à
certains regrettent d'avoir été
instrumentalisé exemple muramato
réfugiés somaliens a bien essayé de
manifester sans succès pendant la visite
de la candidate pour lui parler de ce
qu'il appelle la réalité de ce conte
qu'il compare à une prison à ciel ouvert
car sans formulaire de demande d'asile
impossible de sortir se promener
ici c'est une prison parce qu'on ne sort
pas on mange mal nous sommes malades
nous mourrons
marc-antoine pinault est aussi sceptique
sur les faits de cette visite il a
abordé valérie pécresse pour lui faire
part des témoignages qu'ils recueillent
des exilés via son ong et notamment l'
isolement du centre d'accueil ce qu'il
craint lui c'est de voir ce type de
centres fermés s'exporter s'il est
candidat à la présidentielle via nice
pour s'inspirer de ce camp donc si
l'idée c'est de créer des grottes à
l'amour des petits guatanamo partout en
france c'est une catastrophe pour les
droits humains pour notre pays la visite
de valérie pécresse est aujourd'hui
encore un sujet de discussion auprès des
habitants de l'île pour nikita la
candidate aurait pu faire l'effort de
s'intéresser aux paysages aux racines de
samos qui a vu naître le père des
mathématiques
ici c'est l'île de pythagore mais on l'a
oublié ici on voit juste une europe qui
fait couler des bars ferme ses
frontières et construit des murs
une chose est sûre la grande majorité
des habitants de ce hameau s'intéresse
aujourd'hui à la présidentielle en
france
ces réfugiés qui viennent chercher asile
en europe il les emplois lui justement
dans son entreprise de confection dans
l'indre c'est notre portrait des
lecteurs oui on part cette semaine à la
rencontre de patrick hervier il dirige
une entreprise familiale d'une
quarantaine d'employés spécialisés dans
la confection de vêtements depuis
plusieurs générations il est un fervent
défenseur du savoir faire français alors
qu'elles sont pour lui les dossiers
prioritaires pour faire avancer la
france pour elle ce reportage de julie
d'une golf et florence bino
[Musique]
l'historique de la famille herbiers dans
la confection je dirais remonte à 1910
c'était plus une activité très artisanal
donc on allait chez la couturière ou
chez le tailleur parfaire à vêtements on
va être avec ma fille la cinquième
génération de collectionneurs dans la
famille à renier
c'est pas possible de faire ce métier si
vous n'êtes pas passionné parce que
c'est un métier qui vous mange c'est
très stressant
alors ce qui concerne mon épouse et moi
mais nous avons pris en octobre 1988 on
a connu aussi des passages très très
compliqué qu'avec la mondialisation elle
les 35 heures en l'an 2000 il ya donc un
nombre très important d'entreprises vont
déposer le bilan
je m'appelle marie jeanne je suis
et pas du tout même travail on avait des
grosses séries et maintenant non plus du
cas par cas
en 2012 il ya un retour vraiment très
très important du made in france ça
s'explique par l émergence de nouvelles
marques avec des jeunes chefs
d'entreprise soucieux un petit peu du
territoire après c'est aussi un rapport
à l'écologie à s'apercevoir que les
vêtements ils sont faits à 20000 km par
des enfants dans des conditions
déplorables
aujourd'hui le souci numéro un de notre
profession c'est le recrutement nous on
cherche bien sûr en priorité sur le
bassin d'emploi mais on a de grosses
difficultés donc c'est vrai qu'on
recrute beaucoup de réfugiés qui peuvent
venir de syrie d'afghanistan
l'intégration d'une personne en france
elle ne peut se faire qu'à travers le
travail et logement
[Musique]
si j'étais président dans ma première
action est sûre et vis-à-vis de
l'éducation de la formation il faut
absolument que l'on arrive à ce que les
jeunes qui sortent du système
d'éducation nationale à se dirige vers
un emploi et non pas ceux ne dirige pas
vers pôle emploi dans un second temps je
remettrai le mot de travail à l'ordre du
jour il faut absolument que les
rémunérations pour les gens qui
travaillent soient plus élevés pour ceux
qui ne travaillent pas
c'est le cadeau bonus à présent bonus
comme images d archives on va revenir
sur un épisode politique vous l'avez
sans doute entendu ces derniers jours
valérie pécresse qui évoque le terme d'
europe passoire c'était précisément à
samos oui comme de nombreuses figures de
la droite et de l'extrême droite avant
elle voici une archive de jacques chirac
durant sa phase eurosceptique il
deviendra ensuite pro européens au
moment d'exercer le pouvoir en tout cas
le 31 mars 1979 chirac alors maire de
paris s'érige en ennemi de l'europe
supranationale et la qualifie donc d'
europe passoire référence non pas à
l'époque aux flux migratoires mais selon
ses mots à une concurrence économique
internationale je cite déchaîné voyez
donc cet extrait de son discours aux
assises nationales du rp ray rpr alors
qu'il conduit la liste néo gaullistes
aux élections européennes de 79 rien
soyons honnêtes cette europe de
l'impuissance
cette robe couverte comme une passoire à
toutes les crises du monde
cette europe non européennes mais
dominée par les intérêts germano
américain cette europe du chômage
importé scènes d'europe mollusques sans
corps et sans dessein véritable cette
europe où les sociétés multinationales
dictent leur loi aux états cette europe
où la france serait en plus et comme
dans un marécage
je le dis avec calme et détermination
c'est leur plat nous ne l'accepterons
jamais
voilà il sa posture eurosceptiques sera
un échec sa liste va finir quatrièmes
aux élections européennes de 79 derrière
entre autres celle du président giscard
d'estaing porté par simone veil france
24 france france france 24 france bill
22 sur france 24 lors du choix c'est
déjà la fin on va sur l'ong ir en une
semaine à vous rendez vous à choisir dix
ans lundi prochain rendez vous est pris
lundi prochain mais d'ici là bien sûr
vous pouvez nous retrouver et retrouvée
ce journal de campagne sur notre site
internet france 24 points comme rendez
vous donc lundi prochain même heure
[Musique]